house elves centaurs and polyjuice
potion have
all been confirmed for hogwarts legacy
i'll break it all down for you
here in today's video including a
character from the harry potter series
that has
also been confirmed to make an
appearance in hogwarts legacy
people of the internet retrorec contour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream
over on twitch i want to give out a
quick thank you to all of the recent
subs on the channel we
recently surpassed 600 subscribers
closing in on 700 which is absolutely
incredible gonna have to do something
extra special when we hit a thousand so
let me know if you have any ideas
apologies for my nasally sounding voice
in this video guys as well
allergy season is hitting me hard right
now but
i'm gonna keep the videos coming to you
anyway bear with me though today
the topic of today's video is centered
on a playstation blog post from adrian
ropp
of avalanche software he is the head of
story for hogwarts legacy and this post
is crammed
full of interesting details now this
blog post has
actually been up since back in september
believe it or not i think a lot of
people may have missed it though because
if you think
about it hogwarts legacy was unveiled as
part of the larger
ps5 showcase event so there was a lot of
news going on there
and anytime games are revealed at events
like this they do
run the risk of some news getting swept
under the rug and i think that may be
what happened here
at least for some people how about you
did you already know about this blog
post
if so let me know down in the comments
your most exciting detail from the post
of course all the ps5 news certainly
didn't hurt the trailer which has been
viewed more than 14 million
times on playstation's official youtube
channel as for the blog though i
remember reading it at the time but for
whatever reason some of these details
just didn't stick out to me
until i went back again recently and
took another look so let's go ahead and
dive into this post and see
what details we can find right out of
the gate adrian starts off by saying
how should this character's voice change
when they drink
paulie juice how long do house elves
live
are grab horns omnivores these are the
types of
questions that drive us toward
authenticity and the types of questions
you only think to ask when you have
steeped yourself in the lore
okay a lot right there of course we
already knew about the grab horns from
the trailer but this quote would
seem to indicate that both apollo juice
potion
and house elves are in fact in the game
which is great news am i right with
paulie juice there are obviously some
exciting gameplay possibilities
i think this will most likely be
something we do during the story of the
game and not necessarily something we'll
be able to brew
anytime we want although it would
certainly be awesome if we could
when it comes to the harry potter books
the trio used paulie juice to sneak into
places they weren't allowed such as the
slytherin common room in book 2
and the ministry of magic in book 7.
same for barney crouch jr in book 4 when
he used the potion to pose as mad i
moody
so to me i could see apologies being
used in a similar manner for hogwarts
legacy perhaps we need to sneak into
another common room or maybe a teacher's
office or something
crazier like azkaban or the ministry
house elves are equally
exciting as they played such a prominent
role throughout the series
my hope is we'll be able to visit them
in the hogwarts kitchens and maybe even
have tasks or missions to complete
involving them one other line that's
sure to please all of us fans is when
rob says quote
we take seriously the responsibility of
contributing new content
to the beloved wizarding world franchise
this
is so good to hear for long time fans of
the series
also how he talks about the fact that
they are so steeped in
the lore of the wizarding world already
it's really good that they're asking
those questions
now if you aren't familiar with rob he's
no stranger to working with
beloved franchises he served as story
lead for the disney infinity series
where he had the opportunity to work on
stories from monsters university
cars marvel's avengers guardians of the
galaxy and star wars
pretty big franchises right there
continuing on with the blog post though
rob goes on to ask a few questions that
make it
seem like they'll be exploring some of
this at some point throughout the game
questions like who was the headmaster
what challenges did students face what
influenced their society before tom
riddle
before newt scamander i like to say that
what we are giving fans is something
familiar in a way they have never seen
the more i make these hogwarts legacy
videos guys i'm really starting to
believe that magical creatures are going
to play a
central role in the game i don't think
this is just going to be some sort of
side quest we already know we can tame
creatures and we've seen a number of
them already
in the first trailer tom riddle
influenced the wizarding world by
placing a strong emphasis on being a
pureblood wizard
he wanted to create a society where
muggleborns weren't allowed to use magic
and one where all muggles would have
faced persecution from wizards
it's interesting to see him juxtapose
tom riddle here with newt scamander
newt of course is known for all the work
he did to protect and catalog
magical creatures we still have a lot to
learn about hogwarts legacy but my
theory
right now on the main story is that it
will somehow involve the mistreatment or
maybe even the enslavement of magical
creatures
we already know we'll be able to choose
a path of light or dark so i'm betting
the light path will focus on
caring for and taming the magical
creatures whereas the dark path
will focus on enslaving them and using
them as tools
reading on we get confirmation that at
least one
familiar face from the mainline series
will be making an appearance and that of
course
is nearly headless nick sir nicholas de
mimsie pulpington
died on halloween in october of 1492.
that timing puts him squarely in play
for a game taking place at hogwarts in
the late 1800s here's the full quote
which does go on to reveal even more
we embrace what we know and challenge
ourselves to expand upon it
nearly headless nick would have been
floating around loyal and cheerful as
ever the forbidden forest was still
forbidden and home to centaurs not
likely keen on human interaction
goblins were around but this lot
certainly didn't work at gringotts
the village of hogsmeade was there and
an ollivander has been making wands
since 382 bc
often the difficult task is choosing
which details we aren't
going to explore so not only are we
getting nearly headless nick but also
centaurs the forbidden forests goblins
and an olivander making wands
yes please now going back to my theory
on the enslavement of magical creatures
again i think this continues to work and
fit here because he's talking about
goblins and how this lot
certainly wouldn't be working at
gringotts so this could be long before
the goblins have the rights that they do
by the time we get to harry potter's day
and we already know if the leaked
trailer holds up if that content is
still
in the game we're actually going to be
doing battle with some of these goblins
so these goblins are hostile and clearly
they do not want us being involved in
whatever is going on with them again
forbidden forest confirmed great to see
centaurs mentioned as well
rob then goes on to talk about how
excited they are to be making a game for
ps5 specifically calling out the new
dual sense controller
with innovative high definition graphics
a player can practically
feel the terror of inferior bearing down
upon them since the ground rumbling
beneath them as a herd of angry centaurs
surrounds them
even dueling against a deadly dark witch
takes on a new level of realism thanks
to the controller's ability to imbue
sound and touch into every moment we
already knew and fury were in the game
based on the trailer but man this i mean
this really gets me excited
it sounds like there are going to be
some truly dark moments in this game and
so many of you keep talking about
how you hope the game doesn't shy away
from the more mature
frightening aspects of the wizarding
world and again the fact that we're
being surrounded by a herd of angry
centaurs here this ties
back into my theory that magical
creatures are going to be heavily
involved in this game
maybe even playing a pivotal role in the
mainline story
if you're new here i've prepared a full
playlist of my hogwarts legacy videos
for you to check out because we are
covering this game
extensively you should see it on the
right side of your screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon